what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with another installment of our
beyond omega level series where we
explain the most powerful characters in
comics and since we haven't done a dc
character in a while today we're going
to talk about one of the most powerful
versions of one of dc's most popular
characters wonder woman particularly as
she appears in the witching hour mini
series written by james tinion in 2018
and 2019. so this story actually begins
in tinyon's justice league dark where in
issue number two we see a flashback
where diana is a child and happens upon
a ritual occurring at a crossroads in
themskira now the ritual is being
performed by the servants of hecate
which i think is how you pronounce her
name uh which is basically the goddess
of magic and witches who basically
appears and orders her servants to bring
diana to her and then heke brings her on
the forehead with a hot iron so she
bears hecate's witch mark and so the
threat diana and some of the other magic
users like john constantine zetana and
swamp thing are dealing with is the fact
that earth's magic is essentially
vanishing as well as an invasion of
earth by a species called the other kind
now they go to dr fate for help but find
that he's been trapped in the helmet of
naboo by the god himself and that naboo
is basically inhabiting the body of dr
fate now it turns out the naboo is on
the side of the other kind and then
attempts to feed diana and her allies to
an entity known as the upside down man
who is literally able to destroy swamp
thing with a simple gesture he then rips
the demon blood out of john
constantine's body so the upside down
man is obviously not somebody to take
lightly because this guy basically had
no trouble absolutely decimating swamp
thing and constantine who were both
ridiculously powerful guys now the
upside down man then senses a vast power
source within wonder woman and activates
the witch mark that had been placed on
her years ago and so with the mark
activated diana turns glowing white and
she's able to banish the upside down man
back to his dimension simply by uttering
a spell given to her by zatanna so
already this version of wonder woman has
the ability to open dimensional barriers
we then see another flashback of diana
as a child living on themyscira on the
day after diana's encounter with hecate
now diana's mother queen hippolyta
questions the priestess about what
happened and they basically explained
that it must have been some kind of a
dream or hallucination that diana had
experienced of course this comforts
diana enough that she's able to accept
their answer and essentially leave now
hippolyta continues to question the
servants and the goddess herself shows
up and then basically explains that
their worship had not been satisfactory
and that she'll soon return for the
witch mart and so fast forwarding to the
present day and wonder woman is
essentially with the justice league
petitioning them to approve the creation
of justice league dark in order to deal
with other worldly threats and simply
explains how powerful the upside down
man was and when superman questions how
she was able to defeat him diana which
was really interesting actually removed
her hand from the lasso of truth so she
could lie and simply say she just got
lucky now later hecate would reappear on
earth and reveal that she is the one
responsible for the disappears of
earth's magic and she reawakens diana's
memory of who she is and being branded
with her mark and so as wonder woman and
justice lee dark search for a solution
they seek out a sorceress named cersei
who explains that long ago before the
gods had walked the earth that hecate
had split her soul into five pieces and
divided it among five young women she
called her witch marked until such a
time that she was able to absorb all of
this back into herself now as they
discussed diana's power as one of the
witch marks diana says she could rip the
world apart and zatanna adds that
diana's power could fundamentally alter
reality then when dead man shows up and
basically informs the team that another
of the witch mark is wreaking havoc on
the city of nanda parbat wonder woman
literally rips a hole in the fabric of
reality so they could basically be
transported to nanda parbot and does all
of this with a simple flick of her wrist
now wonder woman then battles hecate for
a while but eventually is overpowered
and then wonder woman is turned into a
pawn of hecate who's ordered to destroy
olympus the home of the greek pantheon
of gods now hecate's ultimate goal is to
destroy the sphere of gods a realm of
the dc multiverse where the gods in
magic originate and one of her other
witch marks somebody named black orchid
is sent to the parliament of trees the
guardians of the green or the collective
consciousness of all plant life in the
dc universe whatever you want to call
them and is able to transform it into a
parliament of flowers it's also revealed
that hecate existed prior to the
creation of magic and that she had
encountered the upside down man once
before and was so frightened by him that
she set up a barrier between the two of
them now later hecate would come to
earth and it was from her that all the
various pantheons of gods and the sphere
of gods itself were born now as wonder
woman continues to destroy and reshape
reality constantine and zatanna attempt
an exorcism to free wonder woman of
hecate's control and while they are not
successful in freeing diana the two of
them do free the other witch marked
black orchid and manitou don when they
do this however wonder woman absorbs the
pieces of hecate's soul that it resided
within them which makes her three times
more powerful not only that she's so
powerful that at this point when she
walks up to a hillside she literally
shakes reality with every step she takes
now still doing hecate spitting she
destroys a mountain simply by gesturing
and then also leaves every place of
worship in shambles except those
dedicated to the warship of hecate
herself now eventually diana begins to
realize that she cannot carry all this
power for much longer and begs the
goddess to release her and to use her
powers to heal magic instead of
destroying it the goddess of course
refuses to listen to diana and desperate
to defeat this chick diana asks zatanna
to use her magic to open the door
between their dimension and the
dimension where the upside down man
resides and although zatanna is
reluctant to do that she ultimately
agrees and the upside down man comes
through the door and immediately begins
devouring heke now as diana's power
begins to fade she opens a gateway back
to earth for the rest of the justice
league dark to go through and uses the
last bit of her power to close the
doorway to the upside down man's
dimension seemingly sealing him away
forever one thing i want to point out is
that this one storyline was the only
time when we saw wonder woman this
powerful so unfortunately we don't have
a lot of feats to talk about but the few
that we do have show just how insane
this version of wonder woman is she had
the powers of a literal goddess could
level mountains at will and could tear
holes in reality itself if she had been
allowed to keep serving this chick and
hadn't been separated from her control
or power the world as we know it in dc
comics literally would not exist but let
me know what you guys think right i mean
it's not our traditional beyond omega
level series but it's really more of
just kind of a character story arc
basically but let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section also
always keep me posted if there's anybody
in particular that you want to see thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace